some of you guys there's no only Black
Friday sale but maybe we should do a
Halal Friday sale if you want qurani a
happy building Quran app for life and
never have to pay again and make sure
that you read the book of Allah every
single day and get reminded this is your
chance go to the link and get a 50 off
for lifetime inshallah I just had to go
through a special age only
somehow I don't feel that special
if you're following
um Qatar
World Cup drama this girl is shocked
about the ladies only line she doesn't
think it makes her feel very special
it's a security line that's only for
women they're separated by men and women
not because women are mistreated because
they are better treated
as an American female living in the
Middle East myself I prefer these lines
when I go places I am moved either if
there's not a women's only line I'm
typically moved to the front of the line
especially if I have my children there's
also parking that's just for women and
it's usually the closest to the door and
as well the Metro lines there's a
women's only cart everything over here
on this side of the world in the Middle
East I'm in Dubai women are treated with
so much more respect I'm from Texas when
I go places here I feel safer 100
percent I will die